I'm Leanne and I'm backstage at the
glamour Awards I have this big box in
and it's full of questions that I want
all the celebrities to answer who do you
envy massively Kate Middleton because
she kind of stole the dream which was
just being a regular girl that fell in
love with the Prince and then is one day
gonna become the Queen where's the
after-after-party I haven't got a home
but an after-after-party cementing
Davina you could always come tomorrow
evening online or you could come to my
house
well the after-after-party is always
aunt's house wherever the Kardashian
goes what is your snapchat filter I
don't even have snapchat what's your
ultimate guilty pleasure I don't feel
guilty about pleasure it's chocolate
oh yeah good choice that's pretty real
straight forward nothing to Naldi what's
the question you don't like to answer I
would never want to say like which of my
kids I like better right at that's a
good one all right who's the best kisser
awesome that's not the trachea well that
valens easy I mean of course you have to
say your husband but it's really
Leonardo DiCaprio but it's fine if you
had to be in a reality TV show which one
would you go for can I choose something
like Bake Off yeah is that a reality TV
show I mean it's real people real people
probably I'm a celebrity get me out of
here
just because I like the idea of a
challenge right what's on yours if you
had to live a whole week without
internet what would you do I would live
a whole week learn two favorite words
love love is a good one uh yeah let's do
without that highlight of your life is
you know do I go like really seriously
American here and say the birth of my
son
even if you are in a relationship who
would be your free pass Oh Sean Penn it
has to be Sean Penn what did you buy
with your first paycheck
my mom at home back in the day amazing
yeah and I was it was a beauty was a
beautiful time Jamie thanks me what
amazed you do you use too much okay
so lately I've become a fan of the
dancer lady in the red dress so huh yeah
I like her she's not big on the like
this one thing highlight of my life my
brother's baby coming into the world
what is something you hate but wished
you loved cheese yeah that mine it's the
one on Pizza I wish I liked it Ryder
stone up who would you rather be stuck
in a lift away Trump or Lord Voldemort
so I think I'll go of Oldham well yeah
excellent choice it bun soon be good
describe yourself in three words three
words perfect perfect
my darling would you like to be the next
Bond well I heard actually I heard
emilia clarke say that she wanted to be
Jane bond and I was like yes absolutely
mother dragon she would kill it I don't
hear just Alba would make a great bond
yeah but I quite like the suggestion of
a female bond we dare man I would you
most like to have a drink with anyone
right now
what is something you
a twist you loved spinach and broccoli
and a lot of other vegetables who do you
envy Oh Madonna which is amazingly
talented beautiful and she still looks
good at her age you can go on a spending
spree in one shop which would you choose
all I know is that I love Chloe handbags
and they're really expensive so if I
could go on a spending spree in any
chocolate with you Chloe
how will you cure tomorrow's hang of it
so I'm quite quite good at hangovers I'm
quite I've got a sore balance what
mechanism where I basically just get up
and I refuse to lounge around go for a
walk eat some good food eat food food
food food
and then around like 4 o'clock then hit
that then hit the wall and crash but the
beginning that you've got refused it
it's a reality it doesn't exist who dead
or alive would you most like to have a
drink with a Sinatra classy choice Darcy
choice what's it like to be extremely
good-looking I don't know you answer
that oh I don't know I thank you you
forget who are you a little bit obsessed
with David look show us your boobs now I
would now show your signature dance move
yeah
and love it